TAKE THE WHEEL FROM THEM
BEFORE THEY CRASH.
OOPS, THEY ALREADY HAVE
CRASHED.
KEEP IN MOUND WEEKS AGO THE
VERY SAME MORONS WERE CALLING
TRUMP A PUPPET OF SAUDI
ARABIA.
DOES IT MAKE SENSE IN NO.
SO YOU SEE THE REAL CRIME IS
NOT BEING A PEPPET OF SAUDIS
OR THE PUTIN BUT IT'S REFUSING
TO BE A PUPPET OF PERMANENT
WASHINGTON.
THAT IS WHAT THEY HATE.
DOUG HAS BEEN AROUND THIS FOR
A LONG TIME, RETIRED U.S. ARMY
COLONEL AND AUTHOR OF "MARGIN
OF VICTORY" AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
I CONSIDER YOU A TRUSTWORTHY
SOURCE OF INFORMATION ON
QUESTIONS.
DO YOU THINK IT'S IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSE TO WITHDRAW TROOPS
FROM SYRIA?
>> OF COURSE NOT.
THAT IS RIDICULOUS NONSENSE.
YOU HAVE DONE A GREAT JOB OF
EXPLAINING WHY PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S DECISION WAS REALLY A
BRILLIANT DECISION.
FIRST OF ALL, PRESIDENT TRUMP
FOR THE FIRST TIME MADE
DECISION TO WITHDRAW FORCES
WITHOUT CONSULTING HIS INNER
CIRCLE.
BY THE WAY, THIS IS THE SAME
INNER CIRCLE THAT SABOTAGED
EVERY POLICY ACTION THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP TRIED TO
INITIATE.
HAS OBSTRUCTED THE AMERICAN
FIRST AGENDA FROM DAY ONE.
SO THANK GOODNESS HE IS NOT
TALKING TO THEM.
SECONDLY, HE STRUCK A BLOW FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AGAINST
THE WEAR -- WARFARE STATE.
WHAT YOU SHOWED ON TELEVISION
IS WHAT WE REFER TO AS THE
"WASHINGTON UNIPARTY."
THE PEOPLE ON THE FAMOUS SHIP
THAT IS SINKING RIGHT NOW.
THESE ARE THE INDIVIDUALS,
LOBBYISTS, LEGISLATORS,
RETIRED SENIOR OFFICERS,
MEDIA, THESE ARE THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WANT TO
CULTIVATE CONFLICT AND KEEP
FORCES MIRED EVERYWHERE BUT
LEAVE THE SOUTHERN BORDERS,
THE BORDERS, TERRITORIAL
WATERS EFFECTIVELY OPEN.
SO DONALD TRUMP HAS DONE A
GREAT SERVICE BECAUSE HE HAS
BROUGHT ALL OF THIS OUT IN THE
OPEN.
HE NEEDS TO REMEMBER
SOMETHING.
WHEN RICHARD NIXON DID
SOMETHING SIMILAR AND ENDED
THE VIETNAM WAR AND PULLED OUR
TROOPS OUT UNDER THE BEST
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT HE COULD
GET, HE WAS NOT ONLY
RE-ELECTED.
WHEN HE WENT TO THE
INAUGURATION HE HAD 68%
APPROVAL RATING.
THAT IS WHERE DONALD TRUMP IS
HEADED WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
FORGET PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON
AND THE PEOPLE THAT YOU JUST
SHOWED ON THE TELEVISION.
>> Tucker: TWO QUICK
QUESTIONS.
I NOTICE IN THE COVERAGE IN
THE LAST TWO DAYS NO ONE MAID
EXPLICIT CASE FOR WHAT THE
POINT OF STAYING IN SYRIA
WOULD BE.
THEY MAKE BROAD CLAIMS WE
CAN'T HELP PUTIN OR IRANIANS
BUT NO ONE SAYS WE'LL BE THERE
FOR SIX YEARS AND ACHIEVE
3-1-1 THINGS.
IS THERE A CASE -- AND WE'LL
ACHEE THESE THREE THINGS.
IS THERE A CASE FOR IT?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
THE SYRIAN GOVERNMENT WILL DO
A GOOD JOB OF ANILATING WHAT
REMAINS -- ANNIHILATING WHAT
REMAINS OF ISIS.
WE WERE IN A POSITION IN SYRIA
THAT WE WERE VULNERABLE.
WE ALWAYS HAD LIGHT TROOPS
THERE AND THEY WERE UNDER
THREAT OF ATTACK.
WE WAITED FOR ANOTHER BEIRUT
BOMBING TO OCCUR BETWEEN THE
TURKS, IRANIANS, KURDS AND SO
FORTH.
ISRAELIS IF THEY WANT TO GO
THERE AND ATTACK ANYTHING THEY
THINK IS A DANGER TO THE
SECURITY, I THAT CAN DO SO.
WE ARE OUT OF THE WAY.
>> Tucker: AMEN.
I'M NOT A CONSPIRACY NUT.
WOULD IT SHOCK YOU IN THE NEXT
WEEKS OR MONTHS ASSAD USED
CHEMICAL WEAPONS AGAINST HIS
PEOPLE ONCE MORE?
AND LO AND BEHOLD WE CAN'T
LEAVE SYRIA.
WOULD IT SURPRISE YOU?
>> 'S HOPE THAT PRESIDENT --
LET'S HOPE PRESIDENT TRUMP
LEARNED FROM THE PREVIOUS
EXPERIENCE AND WE DON'T HAVE
TO GO DOWN THE ROAD AGAIN.
>> Tucker: I HOPE SO.
>> BUT HE HAS MOMENTUM NOW AND
HE CAN MAKE PROFOUND CHANGE
AND GET RUD OF THE PEOPLE IN
THE WHITE HOUSE AND DEPARTMENT
OF DEFENSE WHO ARE AGAINST HIM